okay today I'm going to talk to you
about energy and biomass I'm going to
get started by talking to you about how
energy is transferred through a food
chain so all food chains start with
plants there are producers this means
that they can produce their own glucose
how do they do this
well they do this through the process of
photosynthesis so the light energy from
the Sun is really important approach for
the process of photosynthesis that allow
plants to produce their own food in the
form of glucose so what happens next now
in a food chain we can show this energy
being transferred by an arrow
now apologies for the drawing but here
this shows that this rabbit has eaten
these plants so that energy has been
passed from the plants to the rabbit
notice how this arrow it goes from the
plants to the rabbit to show which
direction the energy has been
transferred in let's then say that this
that this energy sorry this rabbit then
gets eaten by this Fox okay so the
energy has now been transferred from the
rabbit to the Fox now the question is
has a hundred percent of this energy
gone from the plants all the way up to
the Fox the answer is no this is because
at every single level energy is being
wasted so for example this rabbit here
during its life time it will be moving
around which will require and mean it
will be using energy it will be keeping
its own body heat up which requires
energy and all of the other things that
this rabbit does during its lifetime so
lots of that energy is being wasted this
means that not all of the energy makes
it up to this Fox here so that the hot
herb the higher you go up the food chain
the less energy is transferred these
different levels in a food chain are
called trophic levels so what does any
of this got to do with biomass now what
biomass is
figure whenever we think of bio we're
thinking of living things that's what we
studying biology and mass is about
weight
so what biomass is is how much each of
these things collectively together would
weigh so let's have a quick think about
what a pyramid of biomass would look
like for this particular food chain now
the bottom part of a food chain the
bottom part of a soil the bottom part of
a pyramid of biomass is always the
producer so we start with a producer and
then we work our way up different
trophic levels okay now let's say these
plants here so these are our plants
let's say they weighed a thousand
kilograms so all of these plants
eaten by the roads with a thousand
kilograms how much mass where our
rabbits have would it be the same would
it be more or wood even less now the
answer is less now this is because this
is because energy is lost from this
stage to this stage so as a result we
can't have exactly the same mass of
rabbits being able to survive off these
plants similarly when we transfer the
energy from the rabbit to the Fox and a
higher trophic level on a higher trophic
level we've again got a lower mass again
because energy is lost at this stage so
if energy wasn't lost these we wouldn't
necessarily have to have less mass each
time but because energy is lost the
higher up we go so the higher trophic
levels will have a smaller mass so that
is basically how energy and biomass
works I think